[Music]
it's nice to see you so nice to see you
too I was asked several times if we'd
ever met and I was like I don't think so
we've met three times no we have not no
I'm kidding oh my God I was like oh my
God oh my God they asked me the same and
I feel like we have but I just feel like
if it might have been in passing then
because they asked me to they always ask
me because I've been in the industry
doing other things right so I and I'm
like I don't think so but I don't know
it might have been passing or something
I do but if you don't really remember I
don't remember then we definitely maybe
we just see each other in things and
we're like we know each other yeah no I
think I see you on TV you have a TV show
right yeah a little bit yeah okay I
think maybe that's yeah this probably
yeah do you ever do that by the way have
you ever run into someone and you're
like you think you know them and then
you figure out they're like someone in a
film or something oh always okay that's
totally happening I didn't say anything
but like I was in an elevator and I was
like I no you don't know that person
there and it's like you don't don't say
anything you don't know them um wait I
just mentioned City Slickers which is
one of my favorite movies I know it's a
long time I've never been mentioned on
anything I've ever like cities like are
you serious yeah it's very rarely talked
about in the in the Uber you know what I
mean I thought I was
asking about the film you're asked about
all the time like since you're a kid
okay I mean kind of I mean China it's a
very special movie for me because me too
I love that movie so much yeah and I
just thought it was so crazy so how did
you end up doing that movie you were
young right I was uh 11. oh my gosh I
know it's the first thing I ever did was
I was 11 years old the first thing ever
to do was with that cast yeah sure
pretty incredible I know well it's weird
well it's weird because my my parents uh
made movies and you know my mother's a
writer and so it was a night Billy
Crystal was actually at our house
um and yeah yeah and uh I was 10 or
something like that and at the end of
dinner they were everyone's leaving and
I was just so enamored by him you know
like I was like oh my God yeah and I
just picked up a chair and I offered it
to him as a parting gift
I was like here's a party favor I like
handed him and he thought it was so
funny because it's and I was I was just
wanting to give him a chair genuine like
take this I just didn't know what you
know when someone's like and you just
want to give him something and you're
like you're just like just take take it
you know what I mean that's how I was
and he loved the mirror of this dinner
and he was like that kid's got something
special
little did he know but yeah oh my God
that's amazing home audition for this
new movie that I'm doing because I need
someone to play my son and then I did
and then I got the part cool yeah did
you ever have any real jobs like regular
jobs like like I mean wait for it I just
heard no no no no it makes total sense
by the way because I mean like in life
like a normal average I've had a lot of
like normal jobs you're just no no no of
course you're right doctor's not and you
play no it's not fun it's being a
musician same thing yeah a fake but no
but we do no but I mean I'm not like
actually playing like someone I'm not in
the military I'm not actually playing
I'm not doing those I'm not that thing
I'm playing it but so it's not he's a
little not real but I just feel like a
nor yeah a normal job I got it like I
worked at Papa John's
apologize no I didn't work at Papa
John's okay I was uh a lifeguard oh no
that's a yeah yeah another real job what
they're excited about that that's
another real job yeah yeah
anyone's life uh well in a way what does
this mean
well like I didn't I wasn't like um it
wasn't like Baywatch necessarily it was
more like I was like I guarded the beach
like meaning there was like a public
beach and a private beach and I had to
tell people to not come onto the private
beach oh
so like you were the person to remind
them of what level they were at
home
you're fun over here you're not allowed
there but like it was more like it was
it was just like a mark guy just a
boundary marker you know and I and I
most of the times had to get up and be
like sorry and then people were just
pissed you know yeah and uh
a beach bouncer basically that's exactly
yeah that's better actually that's cool
sounds cool yeah but then I also had to
do other things like first aid and stuff
like that that's cool yeah that was I
actually took a class like I know how to
do CPR I enjoy learning stuff like that
I do too it's really important yeah I
think it's really important yeah I think
it's good when I had kids I was like
don't die I did everything to learn to
like for them not to die that's a good
plan yeah I mean just I feel like I'm
killing it yeah
yeah anyway so the thing is is that
I respect that you're hard working at
your normal job
um
no job at my fake one but the thing is
is that I like one time somebody got
stung by a jellyfish like a man of war
oh I've been stung by jellyfish it's no
fun yeah like a big one or like a tiny
one I don't know how big it was but it
hurt like hell and I had to pee on
myself yeah
they were like you got to pee on
yourself and everybody's like she's not
gonna be able to do it and I was like
going like
I was like will it take away the burn I
will pee on in front of anyone maybe
well I uh that's what I had that's what
I decided
well they told me that that was what you
had to do and a person was in jail
I I suggested I I suggested that that
they that we should use p is what I
suggested it and and um they they at
that point you know the pain of us of a
jellyfish thing they would they would
they wanted it they'd take anything
really they could
huh well I didn't really pee on them oh
okay I
started
okay
[Laughter]
do what you need to sometimes I tell you
what Save a Life you know what I mean
right we were talking about your job
your job your real job as a lifeguard
but you were also a sous chef as well do
you still love to cook I love cooking
yes how did
you like cooking yeah I just just really
want to like it and I go in there and
there's like two things I make that I'm
like cool but like I just really want to
be into it what got you into it I think
well my family all cooked together when
I was oh well and my dad did a lot of
cooking and my mom did too my dad did
the mostly the like warm food cooking
and my mom did the cold food cooking
like she would make a killer salad and
then my dad would make like the you know
protein or whatever you know yeah and so
but we always got like best a long best
at the at the table you know it was like
the conversations we'd have and the food
we all love food so I started to just
love it I don't really know where it
came from I just love eating so then I
was like well I'm into that part
love that part I just I can't yeah I try
I'm trying and we do so many cooking
things on the show yeah and I'm trying
to get into it but every time I get in
there I'm like or I could read you don't
have to this is the thing yeah I think
that there's a lot of pressure
yeah I mean I do think there's a lot of
pressure on needing to be able to cook
somehow and I don't know what it is and
I you gotta love it like you just I feel
like are you healthier though because
because that's why I feel like people
that I know that cook are generally
really healthy yeah um I'm not like a
shiny example of that so like I I think
that no I eat really good things but I
also really love bad things yeah but you
can you can cook bad things and like
with good ingredients well if you love
something you can be like I love this
thing and then I'm going to find the
ingredient doesn't have to be really
good ingredients you just start cooking
it and then you're like oh I'm gonna try
it this way and try it that way and then
you just do it differently and then it
changes stuff you know I have tried
several times with healthy ingredients
and sometimes I'm like no no yeah it's
funny you say that because I just I
tried to bake this thing the other day
that's in this amazing I love baking
yeah I do love baking not cooking
I mean it's sort of
different I'm not going to argue with
you there that's right I feel like
that's a very it takes no fun it's just
like it's not true no I feel like it's
all the Bakers in the world just went
like it takes no thought no it takes
like
you're in a fake job yeah you fake Baker
I feel like because with cooking they're
like a dab a splash of you know pinch
and I'm like that's relative oh I mean
and you need actually I need it I need
the chemistry like like and all the
scientists hate you too no I just need I
need the I need the recipe and I can
follow it to tea and I'm good at baking
yeah I mean I I understand I think
baking is really hard I think it's
harder oh I love baking well there we go
good at that okay what did you bake
though I I baked this like uh like um
flourless chocolate meringue cake oh I
love my from this amazing book by this
woman rain is hard yeah oh shut up
no mine is so hard for me I mean I screw
it up how do you do it not well do you
to use an electric mixer do you use like
a whisk I I've done both I've done both
I've literally lost a competition to my
tour manager once on a pie because of
the meringue it was a sad meringue
really yeah what did you do though did
you use like a healthy ingredient it
didn't work out well yeah I tried that's
what I tried coconut sugar which is just
a no not real no-go for for an egg white
I do just need regular sometimes you
just need the bad stuff you just need
regular sugar it's like monk fruit my
fruit's wonderful I love monk fruits
yeah you need to you need to go for you
know real sugar it really makes those
those stiff peaks you know yes and
that's what you need for a meringue you
know what I mean I use real sugar I just
sucked at it um
so so your new movie since you're not an
actual Chef or I know or do anything
normal yeah it's fine I don't think no
you have no real job it was hard to walk
out here
I'm so sorry so your new movie is called
the Covenant so can you tell everybody
what it's about yeah it's a it's a story
about uh Special Operations uh sergeant
and an Afghan interpreter
um who sort of become likely kind of uh
connected uh and basically it's a story
about repaying a debt you know it's a
story about
um
somebody who one guy who does something
for the other one basically saves his
life and and in the end you know uh
despite what he wants to do my character
uh goes and saves his
um and I think that's like it's a very
simple story but it's parable about two
people just doing good despite
themselves which I love because I think
you can sentimentalize doing good a lot
like oh you should do what you know is
right yeah and like sometimes you do it
begrudgingly sometimes you're like oh
yeah you know and I love that about it
because I think that speaks to the best
parts of us that we don't even know are
the best parts of us yeah you know and
that's what the movie's about so you are
into music and Music Theater and you
worked with Stephen Sondheim once right
I did what did you do with them we did
Sunday in the park with George oh my
gosh yeah that's so cool
he looks like a Paparazzi but I like did
we rotate it was I trying to get a
picture with it yeah yeah I'm like take
the picture now
[Laughter]
I think that picture's taken opening
night uh yeah he was he was a in I mean
he was he's a legend you know yeah and
he he was really um he loved puzzles you
know that was the most amazing thing
about what kind like putting them
together or like all different puzzles
okay I mean like me too I love crossword
yeah he loved crosswords he loved but
like any puzzle can get his hand on and
his songs his lyrics and his
storytelling is all like a puzzle so
like when you were performing anything
he was doing you always constantly every
night trying to unpick the puzzle for
the performer as you were trying to
figure it out and then the audience was
too so there was never a night where I
wasn't like oh oh where am I going uh
he's fooling you with the music he's
fooling you with the lyrics he's playing
with you he's an incredible man yeah
incredible man yeah that's so cool how
people think like that and put things
together and you can see the show a
million times and come out thinking
something different you can do it a
million times yeah the thing you realize
I think as like as a performer in that
space is that you can feel so different
every night and you can add things to it
but in the end the story is always in
charge you know it's always moving the
audience and like and it humbles you
because I think you can come out and be
like oh I was so I remember in rehearsal
once I was rehearsing uh something and
uh with other actor and we came on stage
went oh that was the best best thing
we've ever oh it's amazing performance
like we just felt so connected yeah the
director came back and went that was so
slow and boring you know like I'm just
handed
we were like just shave five minutes off
speed up the pace and let's go and we
did and we felt so weird about it and
she came back Weeping at the end after
that weird the way in which as a
performer you feel what you feel is not
always what what what you guys feel so
incredible as an experience it's so
humbling like and it's different every
time that's what I love about it yeah
you've actually been in quite a few
music videos as well so I have to ask
you like how did you end up this is
amazing you were in blame it with Jamie
Foxx and T-Pain How did that what was
that like was there did they just call
you I had no idea Kelly okay I'm like I
don't know how I got it this is
incredible Jamie Foxx you know he's like
a I love Jamie he's so great and he just
called me up and he was like I clearly
was at a loss of finding people I was
like probably the last I was like what I
mean Jill and all G's not far down but
it's definitely the end of the G's and
he had gotten all through ABCDEF oh my
God of all Hollywood people and he got
there well yeah because clearly because
Ron Howard's in it also so H and gr
Whitaker it was like that's what I'm
saying yeah
like how do you get so it's Ron Howard
me uh Jamie Foxx and Forest Whitaker in
a car in a hype williams-directed video
and it starts off and like they wanted
me to drive this Bentley and like
somehow I thought I was gonna wear this
hat and it was like cool looking and and
and and I just like again he's like oh
James like you drive you drive and I was
like okay I drive and it was in slo-mo
and and the beginning of the video
starts with us but four of us rolling up
to a club like like because how y'all
would do yeah like the one Jamie Ron
Howard and Forest Whitaker and I would
always
[Applause]
and and it was in slow-mo but I had to
hit a mark and there were like these
sandbags for the car to hit so I hit the
mark right for the camera yeah and uh I
just was not familiar with the car and
every time I roll up in slow-mo the the
car would hit the sandbag and we would
all sort of jolt forward so if you slow
mo so if you see the video it's like us
like I'm just like trying to be hard and
I'm just like like this and it starts
and it's just all of us going
like right before it's just it was great
it was great it was actually honestly
because what's funny is when they do the
slow mo usually they play the track
really fast yeah so they're true so
they're playing in a music video and
it's they play the trick track like
extra fast so especially when you're
doing the lyrics you have to be like
really fast and it's and then it slows
it down this was the intro so it wasn't
even that you can't even give me that I
just couldn't drive the car
[Laughter]
oh my God we need to take a break okay
and I need to learn how to cook okay but
because Jake and I are both we both love
music we've got a game of a sing that
name that tune coming up next I'm gonna
kick your ass
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm going